so
[Music]
[Applause]
father we'll finish them together
silence
oh father
you look weary
luffy
end this now your boys sought this out
you're right
these are the actions of a boy
treat them as such
you and i can end this here now
before this further bloodshed we are
beyond diplomacy now poor father
you'll get what he came for
war
and death
so be it
why did you bring us back realize what
you've done what you started i was
protecting my home
come to the healing room no there won't
be a kingdom to protect if you're afraid
to act
the yotens must learn to fear me just as
they once feared you that's pride and
vanity talking not leadership you've
forgotten everything i taught you
by the warriors patience while you wait
and be patient the nine realms laugh at
us
the old ways are done you'd stand giving
speeches while asgard falls are a vain
greedy
cruel boy you are an old man and a fool
yes that was a fool
do you think you were ready
father
thor
odin son
you have betrayed the express command of
your king
through your arrogance and stupidity
you've opened these peaceful realms and
innocent lives to the horror
and desolation of war
[Music]
you are
unworthy
of these realms
unworthy of your title
you are unworthy
of the loved ones
you have betrayed
i now take from you
your power
the name of my father
and his father before
i ordered
whosoever holds this hammer
if he be worthy
[Music]
you